ancient aliens and all that i think what
you said before is it's
we don't we underestimate what the human
mind can do when they're being forced to
do something or
the love of their religion and just no
distractions
they are just moving abundance fund it's
like you could do anything like they may
be tapped into a higher percentage
of their brain that we don't even know
exist because we're so distracted who
knows
yeah maybe the key to it maybe
distraction is the
you know the worst thing for us i don't
know and they didn't have any of it
the way i looked at it is like what
would be the elect we use electricity
for everything because that's the most
powerful thing of the time right right
that's our most powerful phones are
electricity computers everything's
electricity that's our super power right
what would be the superpower if you
didn't have electricity homosexuality
obviously obviously yeah that rock up
there you're gonna get some dirt
that is the spark that opens up the
brain to achieve
breakdown yes yeah michelangelo
elton john eminem the list can go on
of great guys musicians that it just
takes you to another level yeah leonardo
da vinci leonardo dicaprio yeah we're
talking about dead guys lean on the
ninja turtle yeah leonardo the ninja
turtle
he's the gay one yeah yeah there's
donatello as he is the staff oh he's the
purple yeah
all of ancient greece was everyone was
bisexual it unlocks
a higher levels are the gay flag okay
they're gay
orange red purple blue dude they were
gale
gay guys living in the closet yeah yeah
whoa
yeah yeah and also gi joes those guys
they have no [ __ ] wives or families
gay guys
but am i wrong am i wrong there's
something there
i i there's something there i think it's
just you
trying to distract yourself from wanting
dick all the time socrates plato's and
[ __ ] hey guys
okay guys not chasing [ __ ] tons of
extra time because you can just get laid
whenever you want as a gay guy
not worrying about children not worried
about children oh my god notice age
wasn't real yet yeah no aids you're not
buying chicks drinks so you got
enough money to work on your little
projects like learning adventure if
leonardo da vinci was trying to like
flex and like get [ __ ] and like
buy girls [ __ ] chariot rides and [ __ ]
like that there's no way that he would
have had the money to do all these
experiments yeah yeah
that's the thing by the way speaking of
gays john travolta gay andrew jessenick
gay yeah andrew jeslin anthony
you said you saw a lot of gays in the
middle east right it's kind of crazy oh
no
no no so homosexuality um
it's super gay there but it's not gay
that's the most affectionate culture
you've ever been between men but it's
not considered gay it's not considered
gay
right but i mean italians are very
affectionate like they're not really yes
they're so effective
well it's just it's just it's just again
it's more marketing it's like it's like
in the 1700s our founding fathers would
wear a stocking
high-heeled shoes and wigs but that's
not being trans that's not being a
cross-dresser right
but it is now you know but it wasn't
back then i think it was a little back
then too
no i think it was a little background no
i'm saying i'm saying what's this
they had stockings on and they had long
hair with wigs they were [ __ ] wild
yeah but but i'm saying like if i went
home with the girl in the 1700s
and i was wearing stockings a wig and
and nice shoes you were a guy
yeah her dad would give me a beer not
gonna happen today
yeah but that could happen at 2020 in
bay ridge can we just take